morning Millennials I can't hold my
breath like I used to
I've been having shortness of breath
recently it's very scary maybe it's
diabetes maybe it's not what it is I
have no clue I don't every time I have
something that's like remotely pain foam
like it's diabetes oh no I never thought
that I'd like well it we have it in our
family yeah it's weird the past few
nights when I've been like laying down
watching TV and I call out to Zach to
complain about something I can't even
finish saying his name like I run out of
breath you know and then I don't have
enough breath feel your fiance no it's
bad I always somehow no matter how tired
I always have the breath in me to yell
at them it's not about being tired it's
like I just
instead Eickhoff it's very weird you
know I had a self-reflective moment last
night I went to dinner at catch which is
the most poorly run restaurant but the
food is so good that like I keep going
even if you have a reservation you're
waiting 30 minutes oh but that's like
any poppin restaurant they want you but
at the bar whatever generating revenue
whatever it's a business model so I went
with Ben and our friend John and job was
just like making me realize like how
much of an Ag I am do you know what I
mean well in that but just like a [ __ ]
where you're being [ __ ] aware you know
just like I was like they gave you a
buzzer so that like when they decide
that your tables ready
it buzzes and so it started buzzing and
I was like Ben go like handle get the
table John was like I guess they set in
a [ __ ] you ever like I didn't mean it
in a [ __ ] you had which is like then go
like move and I mean John was like whoa
[ __ ] and like I guess it takes someone
else to realize like I'm not I'm not a
[ __ ] but like I can just be [ __ ] okay
I'm not gonna change or anything it's
just good to know yeah okay that's good
to know about yourself it's always good
to see yourself through someone else's
eyes but and then this how you like the
way you are yeah and like it's always
good to see yourself a negatively
through someone else's eyes nothing
makes you reflect more and like be more
self-aware than like seeing yourself in
a bad light yeah well and I'm not
talking about physical I I'm glad that
that happened to you and well good luck
today um some housekeeping announcements
I added a fourth show in Philly because
they also
out and added a second chill in Raleigh
whoo if I die in Raleigh at least I will
die free so wrap me so go girl with no
job calm should check it out
I'm also coming to Buffalo ooh and
honestly of all the places I'm going to
I'm at least excited to go to Buffalo
that's really people just be glad you're
going in the summer cuz those Buffalo
winters man with the thing are brutal I
think it might be October but it's still
not bad
October is beautiful upstate I don't
know you know I love out see but I also
feel like it might be super late because
I'm truly only want to live in a world
where like all the restaurants are
chains and like fast food and I feel
like that's what Buffalo is like I feel
like there's no like artisanal cuisine
of Buffalo do you know what I mean
honestly every town these days has their
like original C thing going on like the
whole country's turning artisanal so
it's really bright if Buffalo has like
you know pickled carrots as well also
I'm sorry I hear the demand for Boston
it's coming but as I said it will be at
a very prestigious theater one that
could change my life so it's a very I
don't know the deals being made my
people are talking with their people
that's exciting
by them oh we know I'm really like Miami
nation's getting worse
no it's not that I am in nature it's
like we go down no I do I'm saying oh
well I'm saying we go down these roads
of conversation and then we wind up
sometimes having the exact same
conversation because our brains like
working in the same way that they did a
week ago listeners like that arts like
give us new content new I think they
like it we usually catch ourselves like
Carrie Underwood's husband not being
generates hot boyfriend no he is also
speaking of good new content we did a
patreon episode yesterday that I think
is one of my favorites we made it very
somatic we because tomorrow morning we
have an appointment dr. Sherin easy so
it there won't be a live show tomorrow
just podcast but we were just talking
about like self care and like just
beauty regimens and just like our
thoughts on plastic surgery in general
it was a really good like interesting
educational episode yeah and it was
inspired by our original trip to Sharon
Kesey's office and we took a lot of
toast after dark questions that made us
just think about it very differently and
it was quite enjoyable so go listen
patreon.com slash good morning toast
if you subscribe now you get access to
the video of the anti podcast where you
can see our reactions while we're
talking to him and the morning to a
slideshow from Nashville so if you wait
any longer then you won't get to see
this yeah anyways are you ready for the
past five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast I am and I know
it's not one of the stories but just a
little later on I would like to talk
about xxx tents I own okay is that his
name I have no idea what the same nation
right it's because I thought was
extension but then I realized that's not
spelled right so the Michael Ecsta
nation that's what I think it's xxx to
nation no but like what is it pronounced
as xxx to nation
I think it's extension its oh thank you
everything feel it's wrench Spanish this
story is wild you guys and hide yeah
we'll get to it and we'll pull up
actually a factual basis yeah because
because I know a lot of myths we just
know like the memes around it yeah like
the truth okay first up the MTV movie
and TV Awards aired last night but they
were filmed Saturday night so weird it's
just so confusing and I think it was a
it was a miss for them because I didn't
watch I didn't watch I didn't even know
about it and I know they paid a bunch of
influencers not me
to promote it and like I didn't even
know that it was on last night until I
was at a pride party and there was a TV
and someone walked in was I put on the
VMAs and I'm like what it's not the VMAs
it's MDMA and tv-ma
no it's MV Emmys movie and it's MTV it's
movie and TV Awards they combined them
now whatever but I only knew because
then writer Ross posted that Madelene
one yeah and I was like oh it's right
now good for her she is a scene stealer
and she's an actress and we're gonna
tell you all of the awards and she's
literally the only person that I've seen
who's won an award
oh and stranger things okay Tiffany
Haddish hosted which ad for that's the
only reason why I'm upset with what's
necessary but I didn't record it and now
I wouldn't know how to watch it so
actually I'm sure it's airing on MTV all
day today and like there's the way
somewhere there's a Wi-Fi connection
there's a way okay best show stranger
things one which just over everyone
being obsessed with stranger things it's
like weird their kids leave them alone
I'm not interested never go never given
a chance to don't intend to I'm so over
like the obsession that is Millie Bobby
Brown like she drives away too hard
whatever
is the same machine behind her that was
working on Tori Kelly that was working
on Megan cherry no I'm just assuming
like the same people that are dying for
this person to be famous and be like
universally well-liked well it's not
working because I don't like she has
like a hipster team and I know it's like
mean to say you don't like a kid and I'm
sure she's really nice in person but
like I'm not intern and and she's also
30 years old so yes she's like 6 but
also 75 but stranger things is not a
better show than Game of Thrones in here
I agree
I said that Rize specially for the MTV
audience
totally best performance in a show Milly
Bobby Brown stranger things like sod
best comedic performance Tiffany hey
girls look at the job on the morning
toast Tiffany Haddish girls scream I
heard it was a really tough no but
actually like she was epic in that and
it launched her whole career so like I'm
happy for I totally agree I feel like
the length of this shirt makes my arms
look like disproportional to my body do
you know any mean 3/4 like that's better
okay okay
best hero chadwick boseman black panther
best kiss Nick Robinson and Kenan
Lonsdale love Simon okay I didn't see it
but I heard good things also are the
other cases that were nominated like I
don't even know them before the Gina
Rodriguez and Justin Baldoni and Jane
the Virgin but I don't watch a show but
aren't they like together don't they
kiss every episode which kiss would have
been the one like in the know like a
weird award in the notebook we know the
one can write with the rain it's an
award really for movies yeah Olivia cook
anti Sheridan from ready player one KJ a
pan and kami Mendez from Riverdale but
like which kiss right like they're
dating a charity I'm like do not give
that as seen any awards very
inappropriate I don't want that to get
encouragement that we want to see more
of that no I'm down for a shower seat
dad but not after
not when you're washing your father's
blood off yeah that's when I'm not down
for it and then Finn wolf heart and
Miley Bobby Brown and stranger thing so
I'm glad we didn't get Milly but around
kisses someone in stranger things she's
like six that's wild
okay discuss best reality series slash
franchise keeping up with the
kardashians one obviously was anyone
there to collect know but Vanderpump
rules was there but they didn't win oh
my god honestly like great for the
Vanderpump rules cast for getting
themselves on a blue jet red carpet like
the MTV whatever they're called they're
also like so above
do you know like this is a very
prestigious thing for them to go to and
it's a perfect alignment of it's not
prestigious for them to go to it's like
a JIT real celebrity Kendall and Kylie
or Kris and Kim were there like come on
like they'd be when have they ever been
in the same room as Chris and Kim like
as famous as they are to us in like the
universal universe they're like be- list
at best you know now i don't know most
frightened performance noah Schnapp
stranger things i've never seen any of
the things that were nominated
scene-stealer Madelene past Riverdale
obviously obviously she truly does steel
to see everything stolen nowhere to be
found
best on-screen team all these people
from it I don't know what that is
wow I'm so old like no but like this and
it's like I'm even know the nominees
actually Jumanji ready player one what
what is ready player one no question
Spielberg [ __ ] him
you guys Steven Spielberg read the
blinds poltergeist out of control out of
control no one's talking about it
speaking of the boy I'm not gonna be the
one I did I went live this morning and a
bunch of people were like pop hopping
off about Vanessa Hudgens whines drama
I'll tell you what it is actually have a
hilarious story so when Vanessa and
Hodgins was actually know when I was in
Middle School I don't know how old the
nets and Hodgins was she had a nudie
release and that was like a really big
deal because she was just transitioning
out of Disney like and what was crazy
about the whole thing is that she had a
bush like and someone I remember
literally like it was yesterday some
some boy in my grade showed it to me in
science lab and I was like where did he
like the concept of like finding
someone's new picture was like so lost I
mean now I can find it in two seconds on
Twitter but before that I didn't really
know like how to get it and so he showed
it to me and I was like oh my god I
remember is in a hotel room it was like
red it was nice and so he's with the
bush I need a big Bush and I was like
wow I thought bushes like weren't cool
anymore but I guess she was really like
a kid happy this makes me say and so
what they're saying is that that nude
was leaked because she had sent that
nudie to Dan Schneider like as you know
as all not like she said it cuz she
wanted him she said because he made her
and whatever I can't really spend the
mine cuz I don't remember
but go read it that she said is Dan
Schneider Dan Schneider send it to
Harvey Weinstein and Harvey Weinstein
linked it when she didn't show up for
one of his auditions that's what the
bind says very uncool very uncool Best
Musical moment
wow what a Miss Mike and 11 dance to
every breath you take from stranger
things
even though greatest show me was
nominated for Grammys showed me should
rewrite the stars was nominated we
should have won because Zach ins and
they are so MTV Movie Awards but ho
every nomination in this should have
been greatest showmen yeah Kate sings
landslide from this is us I can't
imagine what that oh my god honestly
musical mom I'm so done with this is us
like and they're just like they're
[ __ ] fake show like I watch it first
season like I was trying to get into it
like I was really trying to be like this
is so sweet and like I just I can't with
the show I can't no I can't
I shan't and I went and truly went and I
never have so I did I miss the MTV video
and TV Awards whatever the [ __ ] they're
called yeah I really feel like I was
there after reading this very in-depth
article right and now you know like what
I miss nothing what's going on with the
children I didn't want to watch a sweep
of stranger things so you know I'm good
the children are really into like horror
sort of thing like your normal scary
movies I've never seen a scary movie in
my life I've seen oh my god along came a
spider is the scariest movie I've truly
ever seen where Morgan Freeman plays a
detective who saves this little girl
who's like the daughter of a very
important senator who gets kidnapped and
like they take her on a boat and it's
the craziest and then like the agent
that more like Morgan Freeman's biking
with turns out to be a double agent and
she's like in on the kidnapping the
craziest maybe well time I watch him
when I was a kid and I couldn't sleep I
left alone otter which is basically like
one big scary movie and I've seen The
Grudge I've never seen any scaring me
and Margo so they grabbed she either
needs to do that like in her ear and she
would literally forgot
cuddy are we gonna get sued for using
their yeah copyright using their aw do
you think I was like special cuz I could
do it do you don't can you do that okay
like everyone could do it yeah okay
anyways congrats to all the big winners
from Saturday night that's being passed
off as Monday night I really need to
know like what the reason was that does
it save money to not live era I guess so
like you don't need the streaming but
they definitely lost so many viewers no
I'm genuinely curious like I know
someone who works at MTV I'm gonna ask
her like what's a success and like what
was the reasoning behind it yeah there
was definitely reasoning behind it I
think it was monetary it's just so weird
to have like a red carpet I mean it's
because they have to big award shows and
they can't spend so much money on both
and if they're gonna do one it's gonna
be the VMAs
I love the VMAs but like you're already
citing so much money on the award show
like what's right shouldn't go all out
to stream it totally I don't know okay
next up this is such a weird story from
Nina Agdal and Jaffrey Oh yuck who are
dating and they allegedly flipped on a
club guests after raunchy PDA session so
Nina Agdal a supermodel ex of Leo's was
seen straddling that is so sad that that
is what she's referred to as like she
has had a blossoming career she was on
the cover of Sports Illustrated and all
she's ever gonna be known for it's like
having dated Leonardo DiCaprio for a
little bit longer than some other girls
he get that and having sent me her
Mansell psycho
once yeah just do that yeah okay it's
page six of course they know everything
with scene straddling new boyfriend Jack
Brinkley cook at Montauk hotspot
Gurney's on Saturday night but when the
couple's canoodling was caught by a
guest
the lovers allegedly flipped a source
says AG doe and Brinkley cook the son of
Christie Brinkley were first spotted
making out by a fire pit at the resort's
Club edik after dining at Scarpetta
that's the same deck buyer Jack where we
saw Tom D'Agostino so so much happens on
this deck it's quite a star if the deck
could talk that would be then escorted
to a VIP area and she jumped on top of
him and started straddling him our
surprise source says they were
dry-humping making out and he had his
hand up her shirt they were really going
at it she was bouncing up and down on
his lap when the gobsmacked guest
started snapping pics of the alleged
midnight mating ritual agile approach
the camera man she said let me see your
phone give me your phone said the
shutterbug PR pro of the incident she
was saying you've got to delete those
but there is a photo on page six of her
because even if you delete a photo it
sees in your trash for like six months
right everyone knows that
big mistake me knock doll I guess you
don't know everything um this is just so
weird because he's legit my age is he
guess like I knew it like I knew of him
growing up and how old is she she's like
twenty six or eight but she's 26 so he
must be 23 okay that's not that bad no
but she just like seems older because
she's tall and I think he's like a very
average height in man and she's just
like been around the block she really
has like no I'm kidding no she's really
pretty
no beautiful this is a weird story
though no totally like you you're both
rich enough to have your own homes like
just go to one and like I'm assuming
they're staying at the hotel like just
yet every get or whatever literally get
a room and also it's like you're clearly
very like had a drink or two because
you're making out in public so like
that's but you won't let people see like
you're gonna go crazy and someone takes
a picture of it like how are you even
present I'm annoyed like I couldn't eat
some high quality footage yeah this is
not high quality yeah but we need real
paparazzi photos young love Christie
Brinkley is dime and a half yeah and
this is actually a good kind of cute
couple because it's like Sports
Illustrated Imam like they have like
similar like blonde beachy like American
Girl vibes yeah I'm kind of here for I'm
sure like Chrissy like it's her
modelling tip they say she was like
someone who looks like your parents yeah
sure thing
okay do you think that's true for you
yeah we do for sure but do guys deep
girls that look like their mom I've only
really heard that girl's date guys I
don't think their dad notice that look
like it's like vibe like yeah she's
definitely Christie Brinkley vibes yeah
no I mean I don't think I'm anything
like Ben's mom she's literally the
sweetest nicest person like and I
wouldn't hurt a fly look her like i'mma
couldn't be more different you would
hurt a fly I do all the time
okay I swear I saw a cockroach in my
house all science yeah well I didn't see
it I just saw like a figure move in the
corner of my eye
better timberlands over it was like gone
but I have an appointment at the
exterminator today anyway was it the oh
it could've been so many things you know
oh my god next just gives me the willies
I know I can't believe you would like
come clean about that um it's a very
average problem to have in New York it's
true
you just moved in wait it's a scary part
I will truly never ever understand how
they get up the elevator it's like you
know they're cockroaches they could
survive a nuclear war they're the only
people no I know but like they take the
stairs like how do they get up all the
way to here they caught him they climb
the pipes
I can't think the pipes the pipes are
crawling okay next Danny Boy see I think
Maire sings that in shits Creek I think
so too
in one of her marionettes lyric Danny
Boy the pipes the pipes are calling
Danny Boy the pipes the pipes not a
that's what I thought yeah okay next up
craziness siesta key Polly Paul was
busted for weed I when I saw this
article I was like oh oh no no not DJ
Pauly D Pauly Paul good I truly only
wish bad things for him they're just
truly a special place in hell for like
boys who called girls fat totally
literally they could die they could all
drop dead
I hate Pauly Paul I can't call he runs
up the guy from Barstow actually might
have been your boy no I don't know no be
someone from Mars some um no no I'm
sorry
was it Bar swell or was it it was like
actually might open bar so or is like
another guy website that's farce tool
bro Bible no but a family first well no
it wasn't hold on let me look no far
stool like some shitty sport reporter
called Rihanna fat like I never do it to
Google he the midnight have called her
Patti said she needs to lose weight no
Porter stands for calling around fats
barstool sports Chris Spags Spagnuolo oh
what a [ __ ] what he said was I think
his thesis was that real like Rihanna's
making guys realize that they're into
fat girls somebody that okay
the piece was based on pictures of
Rihanna from this past Saturday where
the singer well this was a while ago um
where the singer was seen wearing jeans
an oversized button down in boots the
writer said he was worried that
Rihanna's fatness would influence her
fans to get fat too and added so you see
her pushing 180 and it's a tough world
to summit
the title of the article was is Rihanna
going to make being fat the new hot
trend okay I'm done with him spaags you
know him no it's obviously not that
famous
what a [ __ ] no truly like I'm the most
like anti PC like say whatever you want
I get that like some humor is offensive
like I'm so here for it but like there
is truly a carved out room in hell for
boys who call girls that and the lenient
leader of the pack Paul Lee from siesta
key I will never ever forgive him what
he said to Chloe I'm like I know she's
forgiven him just for like the sake of
like a good season too but I will not
not even when he said cuz that comment
was like oh he got fired from Barstow
after that really he doesn't work there
anymore I guess that's where they draw
the line oh no good for them what he
also did was like he would dead take
snapshots of her like in her bathing
suit and like put the whale emoji
literally the devil the dad devil I hope
he rots in hell and in prison and I
really hope they'll stop putting him on
TV like I've finally gotten able to
stomach
Alex composts yeah with his shark
dragging tendencies but Polly Paul I now
I know I'm so out and he brings nothing
of value to the show I'm so interested
like why they keep him on probably
because his uncle he's the producer I
know
uncle but like he brings nothing to the
show
he's so gross looking like he's just
he's never really gets involved in drama
he never he doesn't have like a
girlfriend or anything why you laughing
when he performs with the microphone
that was truly like if you look up
justice being served in the dictionary
you see a video of Polly Paul performing
and here's the thing if you want to go
ahead and call someone fat especially a
girl you yourself have to be stunning
smart rich gorgeous have a great job
Paulie is unemployed lives in his
cousin's house couldn't be in worse
shape physically emotionally or mentally
I just got a DUI oh and he just got a
DUI no he got busted for pot whatever
hot who are you to be casting
dispersions he was on others he was
released on a $1,500 bail that Alex
Campos probably paid he's such a big
deal with bond did you get it back when
you show up to court I think so yeah if
you well depend
so you just have to have the money handy
you don't like actually yeah you need to
be able to get access to $59 even if you
don't really have it yeah either you
have it or both most bonds are like a
lot of money yeah you can also go to a
bail bondsman and like sell your watch
as collateral for bond and then when you
got your bond back you can get your
watch backs that's right and is that
what the show Dog the Bounty Hunter's
about know that show is crazy it's
bounty hunting like when someone is
wanted for crimes and you got to go find
them so yeah bounty hunter but they
always do something with the bond I
don't know Bob confuses me it's a good
thing though because that means that
that means I've never been arrested yeah
very exciting there's a first time for
everything no sister anyways let's start
a petition to get probably Paula kicked
off you get it back if you show up to
court if you never show up you don't get
it I guess that's like good that's a
good way to ensure people like come to
court yeah have you been to court yes
besides for jury duty um no I don't
think so maybe like in middle school
like we went to maka sure ya know or
like let me saw the Liberty Bell AP also
saw the court where they say I feel like
an active court I don't think so I'd
either we gotta go I know I'm sure we'll
hate it
totally ooh Jerri people the over L the
word jure that's still the funniest
thing okay next up Chris Pratt looks
smitten with Katherine Schwarzenegger he
is like seeing okay Arnold Emery is 28
year old daughter they that's like a
very age-appropriate girl which is
shocking which is shocking I like love
and [ __ ] hate Chris Pratt like I love
him because I just appreciate his
Genesis in the business like I feel like
he had a really similar trajectory two
miles teller like they paid their dues
miles teller dude all the movies were a
paid like a drunk college kid Chris
Pratt played all the movies where he was
like the fat friend you know like they
both they did what they were supposed to
do and now they're both being able to
like pick roles that they want to pick
and like just have the career that they
wanted so I appreciate that like the
hard work he put in but I just I know
for a fact that he's a dick and I feel
like he's so mean to Anna Faris and like
I always thought it was weird that they
were together and now that they've
broken up like I can just tell he's a
dick
how do you know for a fact that he's in
it everyone knows that's like a thing oh
really
yeah but like didn't you see how much
what happens I've no he was on no
her Oh maybe when she was not much I was
5 la with Snoop Dogg and like yes she
wasn't what I expected
either you know but like I expect her to
be a weenie like she's she's not really
so popular anymore she's a podcast like
I mean hello we do too um oh you still
love her I did you love him I don't know
maybe it's just Hollywood she when she
was in her house bunny days like the
glory days that was like everything to
me she was on par with like Elle Woods
but she like stopped working when she
had kids not that that's bad
but she just like she just became
different and now she's like a weenie I
think I guess well I hope that they both
find love and it looks like he has they
had a picnic in the park it was really
cute and she's like wearing what's her
name Katherine Houghton Schwarzenegger
very cute it's like so crazy that she's
Arnold Schwarzenegger daughter patrick
Schwarzenegger sister yeah memory
patrick Schwarzenegger was dating Miley
Cyrus yeah I had hope for them me too
but honestly I ship Miley and Liam til
the day I die and luckily they heard
your cries yes they did what story on it
feels like we've all been talking for
two hours we are in Story number four
and we have not been talking for two
hours but we have a lot of range of
stories today you were from business
tech no from legal news mhm
to celebrity relationship news to awards
news also he won the Generation Award at
the MTV Awards and he gave like a very
long speech but anti-bullying you know
so so what know who won part Patrick
Chris Pratt oh sorry I forgot what
you're talking about
how did we come up with Chris Pratt oh
sorry okay sorry I'm just it's just like
it's so bizarre how did they meet I
don't know no Chris Pratt is so hot but
like I just I can't get past what I
think I know about him do you know what
I mean I don't know anything about him
but yeah there's something not right cuz
no one like goes has that much of a glow
up and just like stays normal stays
humble yeah I couldn't agree more
especially a guy speaking of miles
teller there's a guy on The Bachelor who
looks just like him and I took me until
last night to figure it out that guy
Blake I think his name is his the top of
his hair is flat and he went on one on
one
he went on the one-on-one where they're
smashing TVs but that would mean that
Blake is really hot yes I think he's
gonna go really far and we'll talk about
the backside in a little bit I did one
fish and I just you didn't miss anything
except colton lifting up a 400-pound
tree trunk it was I mean they all kind
of did that when Colton did it it was
you want to see a physical manifestation
of how I feel when I don't watch about
tribe I think I think yes freedom
freedom freedom
you gotta get [ __ ] sake nice Thanks
it's just like I don't even know was on
and I was like out to dinner and I was
like I don't even care no it was truly
cramping my style I felt like I had to
watch just so that like we could touch
on it today and I'm in the middle of
starting Mad Men I just started season
two and it's like I'm watching this
masterful television and now I have to
go watch The Bachelorette okay wait
update I'm I watched like ten more
episodes of Sex in the City and this is
the part where she took a break for him
big but then they got back together and
she did tell her friends at first but
now they're back together and like can
you change a man all that stuff it's
Miranda just met Steve here's the thing
I stand by the fact like the whole
season and like you're under this spell
that you believe that like big is this
non-committal like dick who like never
lets her into his life and the more I
watch the more like that is not true
like literally she said I love you and a
few days later he was like I know you're
mad but I didn't say it back but like
just know that like I need to do it in
my own time because I've said it before
and it's gone to me into a lot of
trouble a very mature thing to say like
I don't know I just feel like we were
under the spell like that big is his bad
guy and like so far what I'm seeing he's
not no he does nothing wrong he's the
problem right that he actually she's a
common denominator
he's very upfront with her about
everything that he's not really wanting
to get married that he is like a little
weird but that he loves her and he cares
for her so why is she acting like she
knows none of this and then he does
something it's like a big surprise
because she is just like a child and she
can't understand right good and then
when she had the good she has to ruin it
then when we ran to meet Steve treachery
and the episode with a with a suit where
he can't afford it and then he literally
breaks up with her because he's like
poorer than her that is like I felt so
bad for I'm telling you Moran
is the real protagonist and I know no
one believes me cuz we're still blind
about the fact that she's like annoying
and has short hair but she is the goat
the real like the real show is Miranda
that's like a real problem like she
worked so hard like literally no one
wants a date her because she's rich no
and did you see the episode yet where
she pretends to be a stewardess oh my
god she goes she does speed-dating and
she guy after guys she's like I'm a
lawyer and that's where the conversation
drops off right and so she's finally
just like a stewardess and the guy is so
interesting right and they wind up going
on a date and she's talking about being
a stewardess and like he is like
obsessed with her being a stewardess
it's really funny I'm telling you she is
the goat and also more things I'm
thinking about one thing that doesn't
add up at the show it's like Charlotte
is so like prim and proper and like we
know girls like that girls like that
don't have sex with as many guys as
Charlotte has sex with like Charlotte
has like multiple select multiple
relationships and sex with lots of men
yes I know she waits three weeks but
like girls like Charlotte don't have as
much sex as Charlotte is having she's
also like 30 plus mind until your
friends who are like that reach 30 I are
unmarried
they're fair fair but I'm just saying
like that's a small break in the plot
but it's Sex in the City so they gotta
be having sex and when Samantha dates
the old man and he brings her jewelry
that was great yeah I love Samantha also
there was one crazy thing that happened
on The Bachelorette what not crazy but I
couldn't believe what I was watching so
there's a guy Jean Blanc the perfume
connoisseur and he's been like really
like upstanding this whole time and like
mature and he gifted Becca a bottle of
custom perfume called like Becca Blanc
which is kind of cute considering he's
the Colonus or and then he goes after
four weeks of group dates that he's been
on he was like I love you there's so
many guys left it was on a group date
he's only been on group dates and he
said I'm falling in love with you I love
you and she was like I sent him home
well she was like I'm not there yet like
and I don't think that I'm gonna get
there so she had sent home who's very
good good good and not only does he ask
for his perfume back what he goes I
didn't mean it I just said example
that's what she wanted to hear
honestly I believe it and she like lost
her mind cuz like all she wanted like
she just it that's her worst fear is
someone telling her that they love her
again and they re they don't even mean
it yeah it was so bad I couldn't believe
it I was watching it and Zach hates the
bad charts the only show of mine that
like he won't watch but he happened to
be in the room and he was like sure he
liked watching for feedback that's
hilarious
it was hilarious and then they went to
Utah I literally think they were there
the week that we were there no because
timing wise it makes sense because the
end of the bachelor was like yes you're
right at the beginning of March and the
sky and the snow like the snow looked
the same and they both like it is Utah
looks at sable no like in the sense that
it was kind of melted and it was a
really pretty sunny day we'll find they
went snowmobiling just like I always it
was the same place I know they didn't go
where we went but it looked to the
attacks I love snowmobiling it's like my
new favorite activity like honestly I've
never felt more free I mean and when we
were in Turks and Caicos we went jet
skiing which is like the same thing but
yeah nothing compares to like being on
the top of the mountain and like looking
over and never thought I was like a
nature freak like I literally stopped
every ten seconds to take pictures of
the trees so there's like certain nature
that's undeniably beautiful breathtaking
and that's like trees with all the
leaves gone and just like snow falling
from them it was literally like I was
going insane screaming at the try my
lungs and know I could hear me like it
was the best feeling ever and I thought
it was gonna be like a big weenie afraid
like Olivia honestly I didn't see that
coming like no kind of to have guests me
oh I would have guessed me yeah like I
mean I don't drive I don't you guys do I
have like low tolerance for like
anything like I'm afraid of everything
like actually and I was like ready to be
we were on like a group trails ready to
like be at the back of the trail like
what the instructor being a huge weenie
and like the second I got on it I just
had like a need for speed and we all
really did and of all the people that we
thought in our group like would be like
scared I definitely do not think it was
gonna be Olivia and homegirl was being
crazy like literally she wouldn't move
without the instructor she got lost
twice like she was literally when we got
out she was crying second and we were
like we come back to say I'm done I'm
done and we were get off we're like we
didn't want it to end we're likely do
another tour tomorrow when we like went
inside and signed up and Olivia was like
I mean I can't like I'm not coming did
she go the second time no yeah no she
did oh she did okay like how could she
tell but it's open the second time was
worse
the same instructor and he knew that we
were like now somewhat advanced so we
had a need for speed
I'm gonna need for speed he knew we were
like crazy so he took us on like an
advanced trail where like there was no
markings and I was like literally not
okay
no and it's weird cuz you would think
like snitch she's never driven a car
like it would be the snitch who was like
yeah it should have been understandable
but now she young it's no Olivia like
obviously we'll never forget that that
was hilarious yeah anyways they did that
on her one on one last night and it
looked incredible she had a couple of
good one on one saw tonight and I'm
starting I'm feeling like there's love
in the room okay you feel like you did
my husband could really do that okay
what's our pit story okay this story is
actually like groundbreaking a gay royal
wedding Queen Elizabeth's cousin Ivar
will marry his partner and his ex-wife
will give him away
it's a first in British royal history
Lord I've our Mountbatten cousin to
Queen Elizabeth will Wed James Coyle at
a private chapel on his country estate
in Devon this summer marking the royal
family's first ever gay marriage ivar
who came out in 2016 years after he and
his ex-wife penny divorced told the
Daily Mail that while he didn't feel
like he needed to get married quote
because I've been there done that and
have my wonderful children he really
wanted to do it for James James hasn't
had the stable life I have he continued
turning to his per husband-to-be he
added I want to be able to give you that
that's that is so amazing and during
Pride Week this is so crazy never in
amount I didn't even know that there was
a gay royal and never in my life did I
think that there would be a gay royal
wedding this is fantastic this is
honestly it's the Begum Arkell effect
progressivism non-stop and I'm so here
for Dan it also I'm loving that like I
mean maybe this has always been
happening but I just wasn't paying
attention that like every day there's
another royal event where we get to see
like the glitz and the glamour and Megan
Markel stepping out speaking of a royal
about I have major news oh I have major
new you do you do what better yesterday
on the show if you guys know Kitty
Spencer were upsets where she was best
dressed at Megan and Harry's wedding
she's also the niece of Princess Diana
right
she falls managed so she's the cousin of
Prince Harry and she Prince Harry's
cousin I think enjoys that boils were
allowed to have instagrams well she's
removed enough right because of Diana
being crazy but but also like if she
were Prince Charles niece then she would
have been like in the world but she's
royal by marriage yes so so Kitty
Spencer she does follow quite a few
people like over a thousand but I don't
care so I followed her back and I'm
gonna be commenting on all four pictures
yes Kitty slay yes can her that's what
i'ma say that's amazing it's just so
funny how the world would she would ever
come on the toast
yeah when she's in New York for sure
it's look how well we are she would love
this chair she feel right like right at
home we have a third one for her she
could take it with her if she wanted so
it's not a store wait is this the front
that was a good story and now I'm gonna
pull up a story about xxx nación who is
dead at 20 after he was shot in South
Florida so oh this is all the TMZ
updates but ex Tennessee own was shot
Monday TMZ has learned and an eyewitness
tells us he appeared lifeless with no
pulse the 20 year old rapper was
shopping for moto motorcycles in South
Florida and as he was leaving the
motorcycle dealer a gunman ran up to his
vehicle and shot him xxs was in his
share of feuds but as far as we know
there were no ominous fights between him
and anyone else he said serious legal
trouble he's awaiting child for domestic
violence against his pregnant girlfriend
he's facing more than a dozen felony
charges prosecutor who's accused him of
witness tampering he was on house arrest
but the judge recently let him out so he
could tour he was well respected by
other artists for his musical talent
shortly after the news of death Kanye
reacted and now since his death all this
stuff has come out about the domestic
violence he's good because like I hate
when people that would be like Chris
Brown dying and no one's saying like he
beat the [ __ ] out of a many women like
it's an important anecdote and while
it's definitely sad when people die
especially someone who's only 20 years
old like I'm not gonna mourn this loss
so much a cuz I don't know who he is and
because if you see the pictures of his
beat his pregnant girlfriend like
literally with black eyes he apparently
tried to drown her like okay I'll live
without you in this world sorry agreed
and likewise okay so I think when people
are like such an artist like when he was
alive no one listened to his music but
now he said everyone's like a lost
artist like they also did that with like
christina grimmie lie
I didn't know who she was never liked
her music but no one was talking about
her music when she was alive it's true
like give her the proper proper credit
or lack there up right but yeah we don't
even know him well enough to know how to
pronounce his name and this will elude
me until I go figure it out
it's xxx temptation tend to take long so
you're saying it's French Spanish xs/s
attend house you know it's X Pantheon
extension and what's this time canción
means extension and it's an extension of
Chucky
don't make it more than it is okay okay
okay okay he's a glorified soundcloud
rapper who beat the [ __ ] out of his
girlfriend I'm sure there are a few
people who will miss him but I'm not one
of them
no considering he didn't know him in the
first price so I hope that his pregnant
girlfriend gets the justice that she
deserves
totally and actually she has yeah but
she can sleep at night now yeah and
maybe that's what this was related to
what a scary world we live in
totally people just getting shot left
and right and beating up pregnant women
speaking of not really but Mad Men just
because something crazy just something
like just crazy having if you watch it
after the end of the first season like
Peggy I knew that there was something
happening but like nothing maybe I'll
just say because it's not like a spoiler
the show ended like 12 years ago we know
because I think you're gonna watch I
maybe plan on I don't you would like it
I know I think it's too slow for your
liking and the parts about it that I
like I don't think you would care about
it so she's like she started working in
the Mad Men office and she started as
like a cute little girl I'm like she's
just been like gaining a lot of weight
and everyone's like making fun of her
and is really so mean they even put like
a prosthetic double chin on her like
they change how they design it after
mine it's like very square okay and like
they made her look like really crazy and
I was like she has to be pregnant like
no one just gains weight like right it's
not like we're seeing her stuffing her
face or there's something else going on
and but she's not pregnant and she's
like drinking and living her life and
then one day at work like she's really
not feeling well and she goes to the
doctor and like she's in labor like she
didn't know she was pregnant
oh my god I find I hear about those
things all the time and I just find it
so hard to but apparently they show like
everything is based on things that
really right so that must have really
happened and of course like you know the
father is
someone in the office one of the madmen
those madmen were mad okay
I really do I'm very interested in
talking about a show I've never seen but
there is a rumor going around that Chris
and Jodi might not return to Vanderpump
rules I saw that too what are your
thoughts I think that makes a lot of
sense I think I think it's I'd like her
but she's not really involved in the
main storyline except when it relates to
James and even that is like we don't
play it out and like I think it's just
like those girls that really brought the
show to us and have done the Lord's work
and all the legwork on the show it's sad
but now they're like being phased out
and if you're not a fan favorite like
Stassi you know you can't survive you're
like yeah and but I also think like the
show was giving her so much
she seems really happy in her life and
it's not like she's acting out on TV to
get on the show like if she really were
desperate to stay on the show she would
have done last season or you could be
doing this season like where do you go
from here you start epochal answer yeah
influence her I think she's a t-shirt
line I really don't know oh no this is
like it's it'll be interesting to see
what trajectory the careers take of X
and referral stars because the bastard
like there's a set there's precedent
like you do a podcast you make a
clothing line you make hoop earrings
like you do something you want me to be
her earrings I have to pick out a pair
I'm so saying I I mean I don't own a
pair of hoop earrings because you've
never had your ears pierced my ears
cause I'm gonna put them on later I'm so
excited I just opened up last night um I
agree but I'm glad that Vanner primeros
is doing this because I want to see then
our embryo sale Oh alive for a while and
I think in order to do that they have to
you know they got a refresh oh she's
also a Comique she is Comique right I
don't know it's interesting I feel like
she just kind of likes to chill yeah
like in a Ledge Hill but also pay your
bills yeah if she can just have like a
you know some steady income like a one
sponsor Instagram post a month right
she'll be fine I I'm not worried about
her no me neither and I think Carter
work and I also feel like she has like a
low cost of living like I don't think
she's high maintenance so that's the
thing but the vendor from pearls kids
like no matter how much money they made
they still stayed in like shitty
apartments with roommates
except for Stassi like she's she was
chosen but like they still have window
units you know what I mean
for sure but I think it's just taken
anything no I have a new units ever
announcement of units Oh
they just cover just fancy yeah feels
like yeah it's definitely not central
air I don't read a thermostat no
interesting I know whatever I know about
not having window units no matter what I
saw an amazing apartment that didn't
have window units or central air I'm
like it was a huge jawbreaker what I
know what did have a ceiling fan nothing
you'd have to bring in your own window
and it's like are you kidding me you
think I know how to do that how is that
possible
no that's like madmen they don't have AC
and the salesman comes to the house and
he was like can I sell you some AC and
they like don't know what it is like no
like I said this before I am so grateful
and glad to live in this world like a
world where air-conditioning is s uber
exists you don't have to lie on your
feet to get you places like where cars
are aplenty like I'm very very grateful
for growing up in this age and this era
and I don't want to live in another era
and Ben's doesn't say the word ear are
weird well you know it's your word to
say how do you say it er eh
it depends on your era of the Mesozoic
era the Mesozoic era is in era that's a
bit like it's the end of an era
yeah but it was the Mesozoic era that's
true that's so true I'm a sentence yeah
it was the end of an era end of an era
now I'm starting to say like garage like
you said so many times garage garage era
you know the garage era the griot
anyways that's our show you guys I hope
you are more reformed then when you sat
down at 10:30 a.m. Eastern Standard Time
I know I am I'm Jackie ashtray at Jackie
O problems I don't know why I struggle
with that all the time
because people know who you are it's
like septic yeah also reminder we were
doing podcast only tomorrow oh yes
because we have some appointments with
Sharon Kesey and hopefully will show up
on Thursday looking so different so
that's the hope can only hope and
tickets to my shows alright girls no job
comm Denver I'm coming and that's it
that's exciting you should go to Denver
in the winter yeah you know I know like
Google like famous people from Denver
like local attractions in Denver Ben
Higgins is he really mm-hmm
he lives there mm-hmm I'm pretty sure
unless you eat well I don't think he did
to me they actually are to be with
Ashley I I'm still shook by this
engagement like I just can't even tell
you it's been an absolute pleasure
hanging out with you this morning the
morning toast is the Millennial morning
show we go live at 10:30
Eastern Time every weekday on Facebook
YouTube and then as a podcast apps to
make sure you like us on Facebook
subscribe to us on YouTube and then
leave a five star view on the podcast
app about have a beautiful stunning
gorgeous we are and how amazing
Claudia's voice is actually if you
listen to the podcast you might not even
know what we look like it's not
interesting I mean they definitely do
know but if you have the ability to like
find a podcast totally you will show the
ability to find an Instagram for sure
I'd be hard-pressed to find one person
who doesn't know what we look like that
listens to us
okay if you are out there podcast listen
let us know let us know thanks guys love
you
you